[Music]
now i see the funny side
now i'm always
smiling little fight now
i like that then you're gonna love me
hey there it's mark and welcome to an
exciting new episode of rt essentials
what's that in the sky is it a bird is
it a plane no it's the bat signal so are
people in distress oh wait they just
need help figuring out the best batman
scenes ever well don't worry your
precious bat maniac minds we got you
covered not to say choosing the best of
batman is an easy task there's been over
13 movies that feature the vigilante or
his supporting characters since 1989 and
it appears that there's going to be
plenty more on the way like matt reeves
upcoming film the batman starring robert
pattinson and set for release in march
there's also batgirl starring leslie
gray set for release sometime in 2022 so
one thing is for sure the bad verse is
only growing stronger which is extremely
impressive considering batman's debut in
detective comics was way back in 1939
almost 85 years ago also so many actors
have taken on the role with ongoing
debates as to who makes the very best
batman is it clooney
we put him at it is it kilmer is it
affleck west keaton bale
it's gonna be bale or keaton right i
don't know is it is it adam it could be
robert pattinson oh this is gonna be
really hard and with legendary directors
like tim burton and christopher nolan
there's almost too much cinema magic to
narrow it down to just one list but hey
it's the list gotham deserves and the
one it needs right now so without
further ado here's our choices for the
best batman scenes of all time
i'm batman
batman
[Music]
don't kill me
don't kill me man
don't kill me don't kill me man i'm not
going to kill you i'd like you to do me
a favor i want you to tell all your
friends about me what are you
i'm batman
and what better way to start than with
the first installment in the warner
brothers batman series directed by tim
burton and released in 1989. as you'd
expect this film has all the dark and
eerie characteristics synonymous with
tim burton the director completely
reimagined gotham city cloaking it in an
ominous fog with imposing structures and
sprinkling his gothic flair as far as
the eye can see but let's get down to
the true reason we're here the i'm
batman scene as far as action-packed
superhero movies go this isn't
necessarily an explosive moment there's
no catastrophic card chase or finger
snap that kills off half the universe
it's quite simply a line of dialogue but
sometimes when you have the right actor
in the right scenario one line can be
the defining moment of the film or in
this case the franchise that actor is of
course michael keaton one of the
all-time greats he's won golden globes
been nominated for an oscar he's even
received honorary doctorates from kent
state university and carnegie mellon but
what he's perhaps best known for is
being a damn good batman still
considered by many fans and critics to
be the best
so
[Music]
[Applause]
keaton was instrumental in shaping
batman into the dark and brooding
mystery man he is today the actor even
invented the batman voice that all of
his successors have attempted to
recreate or build upon keaton also felt
like a regular guy he wasn't
particularly buffer athletic and this
made the character seem vulnerable and
relatable you could feel his pain and
tormented past in every move he could
see it in his eyes and you could hear it
in his line
i'm batman was one of those magic potion
moments the right actor the right
delivery and a succinct yet
consequential message also shout out to
danny elfman for his indelible score
and to amc movie theaters who gave me
nachos for the first time the tumbler
batman begins trust me
the original batmobiles were cool and
all and with their overstated fins and
elongated hoods who wouldn't want one
there's also adam west 66 convertible
which was basically just a normal car
with funny gadgets but it still looked
awesome there's the kilmer mobile with
its plasticky looking shell and colorful
innards that went through a
drive-through more often than not even
keaton's batmobile was sleek and stylish
but let's face it it wasn't all that
practical you can't really take sharp
turns to that thing and it's only a
couple of inches off the ground the
slightest bump and batman is stuck on
the side of the road calling triple a
which stands for alfred alfred alfred a
superhero deserves a super vehicle and
2005's batman begins game is exactly
that with the tumblr by far the most
durable and useful of all the batmobiles
the tumbler is a tank with extreme
mobility and an impressive arsenal of
weapons which include twin forward
firing machine guns a rocket launcher
and explosive mines i played with the
toy to make sure
coming right up on his butt
to quote morgan freeman's character
lucius fox the tumbler can also boost
into a rampless jump which he explains
to bruce wayne during a test drive it
isn't until batman is whipping through
the streets of gotham with the entire
police force in hot pursuit that we get
to see the tumbler in all its glory and
wow is it exhilarating batman's in a
hurry to get rachel dawes to the batcave
so that he can administer an antidote to
scarecrow's fear toxin you know a normal
tuesday rachel's riding shotgun and has
no choice but to hold on tight as the
tumbler climbs over police cars weaves
through heavy traffic smashes through
building windows obliterates concrete
walls jumps across rooftops and finally
hops through a waterfall and safely
parks in the bat cave it's one of the
coolest car chase scenes in any movie
ever and an impressive showcase for an
even more impressive vehicle
warehouse fight batman v superman dawn
of justice
[Music]
ah
say what you will about batman v
superman dawn of justice there's no
denying that it gave us one of the most
epic fight scenes of any batman film to
date one attribute that has always set
batman apart from other superheroes is
his lack of actual superhuman ability
compared to superman who has x-ray
vision super speed and can fly without a
device batman is uh pretty human he's
almost always relying on some machine or
tool or riding on his bat cycle or in
his bat plane and the scenes where he is
fist fighting they're usually brief and
often dark and shaky now i don't know if
director zack snyder used this scene to
fill in any gaps left by the previous
films but anyone who's ever doubted that
batman actually does know 127 thousand
martial arts should watch the scene
immediately
first batman leaps from his bat plane
and fly kicks through the multi-pane
warehouse window where countless enemies
await then as these armed combatants
stand guard machine guns pointed at the
main door bad flag breaks through the
floorboards behind them like a stealthy
boss he's there to save superman's
mother martha kent who's being held
against her will so he can't just blow
up the entire place and bounce as fun as
that would have been to watch actually
this is way better because batfleck
delivers a no holds barred butt kicking
reminiscent of neo versus the smith
clones in the matrix reloaded but far
less bad cgi the thugs keep coming but
they're no match there's one scary
moment where batfleck gets shot point
blank by a pistol he's hurt for a second
but he rubs some dirt on it a testament
to the strength of that bad suit
the bat pod chase the dark
knight come on
he missed
much like the batmobile got a modern
makeover and became the tumbler the bad
cycle became the bat pod in christopher
nolan's the dark knight where we get to
experience this freshly imagined vehicle
for the first time when batman ejects it
from the tumbler i know just when we
thought the tumbler couldn't possibly
get any core we discovered that it has a
built-in motorcycle with its own fun and
fancy features for starters the bat pod
is equipped with grappling hooks machine
guns dual front mounted cannons a
chassis that can elongate and tires that
can swivel allowing sideways driving
it's also really fast like really
ridiculously fast when the joker fires
an rpg around at the tumbler in the dark
knight the damage is so severe that the
vehicle is rendered useless totaled
salvaged title in case it wasn't
completely obvious to batman himself or
anyone watching the tumblr's computer
screen lights up with the words damage
catastrophic thank you captain obvious
i'm not gonna yell the check engine
light in my car next
you to do it come time
come on i want you to do what i want you
to do come on
this is where it gets really good though
because the next words that pop-up read
eject sequence initiated and next thing
you know the tumbler starts shaking and
making funny noises then the two front
tires break off and zoom batman launches
out like a bat out of hell racing on the
bat pod blowing up any cars and objects
in his way it's so exciting that you
almost forget the tumbler
self-destructed only seconds prior he's
bruce wayne though he can afford another
one batman catches up to joker and after
a little game of chicken he uses his bat
pod's grappling hooks to flip the joker
semi truck but joker crawls out from the
wreckage and proceeds to walk towards
batman who's now driving at him full
speed joker taunts batman but at the
last second batman swerves out of the
way sparing joker's life and crashing
into another car is this a result of
batman's humanity and desire to be a
good guy
or does he need to take another driver's
edge course
batman meets catwoman batman returns
got hurt ah thank you i was set up to
look like i did this no sweat i'll just
tell the police i was kidnapped by an
ugly birdman with fish breath somebody
said fish
i haven't been fed all day
eat floor
high fiber batman returns was the direct
sequel to 1989's batman with tim burton
returning once again to direct and
keaton once again stepping into the bat
suit though the presence of jack
nicholson's joker was sorely missed
burton brought in a brilliant new cast
of comic inspired villains to antagonize
the dark knight we had danny devito's
oswald cobblepot who also goes by the
name the penguin and of course michelle
pfeiffer as selena kyle aka catwoman
spifer almost didn't get the part in
fact annette benning was originally cast
as catwoman but when she got pregnant
she had to forfeit the role and pfeiffer
was in probably for the better i don't
know that benning leaping around clawing
at giant bats would have been good for
the baby but who knows anyways this is
important because pfeiffer had long
wanted to be a part of the batman series
after almost landing the role of vicki
vale in the first film but ultimately
not being cast because of her past
relationship with
your catnip keaton a girl like me
handsome
dazed
and to die for
when pfeiffer first found out she was
playing catwoman she was so excited that
she immediately began training to use a
whip and taking kickboxing classes all
so she could perform her own stunts in
the film probably got a little too
excited though because she accidentally
cut her trainer's face during a whip
exercise
ouch all this preparation and enthusiasm
made fight for the ideal catwoman and
her real-life experience with keaton
only added to their on-screen tension
like in the scene where the cat and the
bat meet and naturally battle each other
i don't think any two enemies in the
history of cinema have ever blurred the
line between wanting to kiss and kill
someone so masterfully they push they
pull one throws the other off a building
but then tries to stop the fall it's cut
after cut kick after kick scratch after
scratch and headbutt after headbutt yet
it's somehow romantic also shout out to
michelle pfeiffer for delivering the
most iconic meow of all time
sky hook extraction the dark knight
next up we have the sky hook extraction
scene from 2008's the dark knight who is
batman extracting that would be mr wow a
chinese crime lord and accountant who is
also the ceo of lao security investments
with gotham's major crimes unit cracking
down on money laundering services
throughout the city allow fleas to an
undisclosed location to protect the
mafia's money but with all apologies to
joker's question let's be serious you
can't hide from bail man and soon lau's
precise location is discovered he's held
up in a skyscraper in hong kong with an
army of paid guards ready to protect him
by any means necessary obviously batman
isn't swayed by the less than ideal
circumstances and since his memory cloth
cape isn't built for long distance
flights like you know gotham to hong
kong he's got a ride in a cargo plane
used by hired smugglers as batman
infiltrates laos building from above
he's swarmed by guards but fights them
off and successfully grabs hold of wow
dragging him toward a large window and
then using him as a human shield against
the encroaching police force his back is
literally against the wall but timed
explosives blast the building windows
open and batman and lao fly out pulled
up by a small balloon that then latches
onto the cargo plane that is perfectly
positioned overhead
it's a flawlessly executed extraction
and batman successfully brings lao back
to gotham to face justice not that all
superhero movies are required to explain
themselves when something seems too
far-fetched to believe that's kind of
the point of the word super but this
sequence definitely left more than a few
people saying yeah right nolan that
would never work and they'd be wrong
because this scene was directly based on
a real cia program called sky hook also
known as the fulton surface-to-air
recovery system the program was designed
to help rescue downed pilots or fleeing
spies who were stranded behind enemy
lines the downed pilot would deploy a
small balloon strap themselves in and
wait for a passing aircraft to grab the
line and pull them up and out of harm's
way we all stand corrected mr nolan
batman v superman batman v superman dawn
of
men are justice
you can't call your movie batman be
superman and not have a scene where
batman fights superman luckily zack
snyder understood this and gave us
exactly what we wanted to see and
additionally aim to solve the ancient
debate of who would win in a fight
between the man of steel and the caped
crusader unfortunately the clear winner
isn't so easy to determine though
strictly on a physical level it appears
that batman ends up having the upper
hand and superman is at his mercy but
it's important to understand the context
of this fight and the events leading up
to this legendary scene first of all
superman does not want to fight batman
he makes that explicitly clear from the
start of this encounter though batman
refuses to listen and is hell bent on
confrontation superman wants batman's
help in fighting and saving his mother
and feels that their combined powers can
bring down supervillain lex luthor
kent begs fat man to come to his senses
pleading bruce please i was wrong you
have to listen to me but batman
unleashes his fury even after several
violent exchanges kent tries to keep the
peace sadly batman crosses the point of
no return when he sneakily expends a
large dose of kryptonian gas crippling
superman and leaving him unable to
defend himself which batman takes full
advantage of as the sequence plays out
we're left wondering why is batman so
angry with superman and beyond reason
it's because superman destroyed
metropolis and batman was present to see
this destruction firsthand right or
maybe it's because batman feels
threatened by superman's alien powers
and sees him as a threat to the safety
of the entire planet or is like sleuther
masterminding their rivalry and pitting
the two against each other or maybe it's
just a simple case of caitlyn
saving the swat team and hostages the
dark knight
doctors get down live
the next scene was designed to be one of
the boats the best of all time there's a
countdown thugs hostages explosives the
swat team and of course clowns
lots and lots of clowns the bulk of this
scene takes place in the pruitt building
where the jokers placed a bunch of
hostages and disguised them as armed
thugs in clown masks as the swat team
moves in batman has already taken
matters into his own hands attacking who
he thinks are the joker's thugs after
subduing one of these thug clowns and
ripping off their mask he informs fox
that the swats are targeting the wrong
people and that the clowns are actually
the hostages and i love that i just got
to say that sentence
we got him he's out of the game
[Music]
commissioner gordon is preoccupied with
a distressing phone call courtesy of two
faced and the swats are already in
motion with snipers on the adjacent
rooftop and their entry team quickly
climbing the stairs in that moment
batman has no choice but to fight the
swat team to keep them from killing the
hostages they believe to be the
criminals it's complete chaos and once
again batman appears to be the bad guy
when in reality we know he's the hero
the joker's ruse is eventually uncovered
and batman does end up saving hostages
and keeping the swat team mostly safe
but not before some serious edge of your
seat action and some likely hospital
bills batman interrogates joker the dark
knight you've changed things
forever then why do you want to kill me
i don't want to kill you
what would i do without you go back to
ripping off mob dealers no no
no
no you you complete
me you're garbage you kills for money
don't talk like one of them you're not
even if you'd like to be
last up we have the scene where batman
interrogates joker in nolan's the dark
knight this film is considered to be one
of the greatest if not the single
greatest batman ever made christian bale
is brilliant as always and michael kane
gary oldman aaron eckhart maggie
gyllenhaal and morgan freeman are all
top shelf but what really set this film
apart was heath ledger's portrayal of
the joker just stepping into that role
in the first place would have been
difficult knowing that nicholson had
already set the bar so high the ledger
not only accepted the lofty position he
also completely reinterpreted the
character and added a layer of depth
never before reached by any super
villain the true brilliance of ledger's
joker can be witnessed during the
interrogation scene where batman
impatiently demands to know where dent
and rachel are being held the joker gets
inside batman's head playing
psychological tricks and frustrating him
to the point that he becomes agitated
and violent
where are we
killing is making a choice
where are they choose between one line
for the other your friendly district
attorney or his brushing bride-to-be
you have nothing
nothing to threaten me
one line of jokers is especially
poignant when he says to them you're
just a freak like me they need you right
now when they don't they'll cast you out
these words cut like a knife and you can
feel batman's anger shift to emotional
pain in this moment but he snaps out of
it and lifts joker up by his shirt once
again demanding answers the joker
doesn't let up and though batman
continues beating him he just laughs
harder and talks more almost
re-energized by the pain according to
bale this was their first scene shot
together and he saw that heath ledger
was quote a hell of an actor who's
completely committed and totally gets
the tone that nolan is trying to create
bale added that ledger demanded to be
hit for real and was egging him on
during takes ledger's portrayal of joker
won him a posthumous oscar for best
supporting actor and goes down in
history as one of the most haunting and
remarkable performances ever regardless
of genre and there you have it our picks
for the best batman scenes of all time
as always we couldn't cover every iconic
batman scene to ever hit the big screen
but there's plenty more episodes of rt
essentials on the way so fear not i'm
sure we'll get there eventually thanks
for tuning in i'm mark ellis and
remember
you
complete me
[Music]
[Music]
you